what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey
I started did you know series to try to
get to know some of the successful
experience with profiles it a little
more personal way share some surprising
facts about them that maybe you don't
know yet and give you a little bit of an
inside peek into their lives and who
they are so today we're going to learn 9
surprising facts about Oprah Winfrey
[Music]
facts number one her original name was
Orpah after the biblical character in
the Book of Ruth and her aunt named for
that it's on her birth certificate but
so many people mispronounced it and
called her Oprah that eventually the
name just stopped I was born as I said
in rural Mississippi in 1954 and I was
born at home and there were not a lot of
educated people around and my name has
been chosen from the Bible my aunt Ida
had chosen the name but nobody really
knew how to spell it
so it went down as Orpah on my birth
certificate but people didn't know how
to pronounce it so they put the P before
they are in everyplace else other than
the birth certificate so on the birth
certificate it is Orpah but then it got
translated to Oprah and so here we are
but that's great because Oprah spells
Harpo backwards I don't know what or who
spells so Fox number 2 50 cent named his
dog Oprah after her and his cat after
her best friend Gayle let me ask you I
heard you have uh you have a dog named
Oprah yes it is that a compliment yeah
whether you meant it to be won or not
loved you know if you have dogs in
assessment yeah I know I've had 22 dogs
in my
five right now okay but you named your
dog Oprah that was not the compliment as
I said I got a chance to name girl
hahaha
and I was looking for real cute names
for pet did people would you still have
the dog named Oprah yeah I got a
babysitter for Wow that's right with dog
nanny I call it dog no new dog nanny
okay why did you name your dog Oprah at
the time I was just looking at the
situation and I was developing negative
feelings for someone who doesn't even
know me yeah and then I give to the door
because I was excited about the dog at
the time so now do you have greater
affection for me absolutely happy for a
few years now I take pictures right I
say crazy stuff on Twitter but an impact
because there was associated too many
sanity
I know [ __ ] number three she helped to
launch dr. Phil's career I feel like I
raised this dude and I can let me just
tell you I had a moment I had a moment
driving in and seeing your big face on
the side of the Paramount wall I must
say Wow
and it all started because we were going
through I was going through a hard time
what was it 98 was 98 and we worked for
two years before that that's right so
we've been knowing each other 20 years
no I I was knowing J was in high school
because I remember J came time to
testify and he said not less Jason
Sergei's here she called Jays High
School and said I need him out of class
and the principal went to his class and
said somebody that sounded a whole lot
like a friend just called and said they
need J McCloy what it was because J Jay
and I became friends and I just wanted
somebody hold my head so we did that
trial and then I said to Phil I wanted
you to come on television and do for the
other people what you had done for me
Park number four she once competed in
Miss black America I remember back in
1901 when I was a contestant that I just
was so excited about being there I
considered it a major accomplishment
just to get there and represent my state
in its thing I remember being so nervous
and upset when all the girls at least I
thought all the girls at least appeared
to be all the girls got flowers from
home from their boyfriends and I was
digging this good at the time who did
not been me not even one single solitary
rose and I remember being so upset about
it and was Miss Iowa who said to me it
really doesn't matter if you put a
flower on your mind and so I left that
kind of carry me through the contest
having that flower in my mind and
deleting anything was possible and just
enjoying the experience and although I
didn't play I went home with a flower in
my mind and pretty good fact number five
she considered starting a girls school
in Africa to be one of her greatest
accomplishments as a mother as just a
person who has been a part of your lives
for the past four or five years I've
never been more proud I think you all
exemplary you made me a really proud
mama she may not have biological
children but thanks to the first
graduates of the Oprah Winfrey
Leadership Academy for Girls Oprah says
she now understands the trials and
tribulations as well as the joys of
parenthood all seen in the documentary
the first graduating class so when they
call you mom Oprah that's for real
juju if you were there more than 10
minutes they call you a sister Joe no
matter who you're with no matter what
you're doing if one of these girls calls
you pick up the phone oh yes now we're
all texting all the time matter of fact
it just happened this morning and I was
on the phone last night for an hour with
one of them trying to watch the debate
like okay trying to watch the debate but
okay I hear what you're saying yes I
think I've come into my mothering space
in a way that was holy holy so
unexpected I just I I I knew from the
moment that I met these girls that I was
going to fall in love with them and I
did
the maternal bonding again five years
ago as a leap of philanthropic faith
inspired by the venerable Nelson Mandela
what is the single training trajectory
changing moment for me was being exposed
to a world of Education that offered me
a new insight into how I saw the world
so I just wanted to do that for somebody
else that's all box number six she
started going to school at the age of
six already knew how to read and was
consistently ahead of her classmates
first day I went to school I was in a
classroom by the time I was a you know
six years old didn't go to school I was
six years old cuz I was my grandmother
that time sure but she had taught me how
to read read the Bible Bible stories so
I went into the classroom knowing
Nicodemus Shadrach Meshach and Abednego
I could spell all of those words I
thought I was you know I was preaching
to the to my kindergarten teacher at
gova she's like who is there so I was
never placed in an environment where I
was ever made
to feel inferior I always felt like I'm
the smartest kid in this room and
because I was never place and it never
put in a position where I was made to
feel less than I didn't grow up feeling
less than you know and there is that
they say is history in the residences of
Drury and it's all about what you
believe you know I say this too when I
do something on my network now called
life class the fundamental key to
success is what you believe is true for
yourself not what you want not what you
desire it's what do you believe you know
you can say I wanted I want to be the
most successful person in the world but
if you believe that there's a glass
ceiling and you're going to have a hard
time kicking through that glass ceiling
curiosity will be defined by the glass
ceiling and the great beauty and gift of
my life is that I was never defined by
the box that other people tried to put
me in fact number seven in 2011 she
received an honorary Oscar for her
philanthropic unimaginable that I would
be spending before you voted by the
Board of Governors drama at the
governor's Awards as Oprah Winfrey
accepted the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian
Award from the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences I don't know of anyone
anyone who would be more deserving what
this really means is that all of us can
make a difference through the life that
we live Oprah Oscar nominated for the
color purple was honored for her
philosophy she's always thinking about
how she can help others increasing the
the literacy level of this country by
your mere passion for books
box number eight she reigned the Marine
Corps Marathon with her trainer Bob
green I vowed that I was going to run a
marathon even though I was all blowed up
at the time I agree
that I was going to work on myself and I
was going to going to run a marathon by
the time I turned 40
well it was my biggest dream ever and
four months four months you know you
have to train so that you can handle the
26 miles here's some of the training
okay so this is August 9th and we're
about eight and a half miles into a 15
mile run all the part of the training
for the 26-mile marathon
I've been running now for exactly two
hours straight
exactly I've had to stop to wee Willy
Winkle or time the bad Willy Winkle day
for me Bob just said well you say hey
got some good news way after today you
only have 10 more long ones like don't
tell me no bad news okay okay so that
was just a part of the training two
weeks ago I ran the Marine Corps
Marathon in Washington DC and this was
the real deal we got to the race site
about an hour before to start time
it was pouring rain I didn't expected
that as I made my way to start I was
feeling a little nervous really anxious
and a lot of pressure as all the
photographers surrounded us
alright guys give it a pass here can we
close it thinking what have I gotten
myself into I finally made it through
the crowd their spirit hadn't been
dampened at all by the downpour and then
I got the last little good luck again
and tried to calm myself as the national
anthem played
[Applause]
I was really anxious to get going
the starting gun sounded 15,000 runners
took off at 1:00 I knew they were going
to swallow me and they did
I was swallowed by the massive tackle
all those marathon about 37 minutes into
the run I looked at my watch and said
remember this because you're feeling
pretty good to tabloid reporters were so
dead set on getting the scoop on my
first marathon they actually ran the
race alongside me
[Applause]
this was my worst nightmare I had to pee
and there's a National Enquirer runnin
next at Mile 16 I've been running for
almost three hours we rounded the
Capitol I was feeling pretty good as you
can see the rain wasn't letting up
miles 19 through 21 whoa those batons
lots of runners were dropping out
slowing down walking just too tired to
go on
I've been running at that point for
about over four hours and I was starting
to hurt
the crowd was great as I was nearing the
final few miles the momentum of the
crowd helped to carry me people always
said it would feel like this and it was
the greatest feeling I believe I've ever
had
I started to cry when I saw that 26 mile
marker and realize my dream in fact
number nine for a period of time she
sang the theme song for her own show
[Music]
I believe I'll run home he would be a
little bit evil work all right I would
wait for me
I keep ting down the stories and more
exact dream the angel here on earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video did you learn something new about
Oprah that you didn't know before how
many of the nine surprising facts did
you not know I'd love to hear from it
share it down the comments below also is
there something we missed is there a
number 10 number 11 that you want to add
to the list that people may not know I'm
really curious to find out share that in
the comments to thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your when where it is much love
see see